I do often wonder if vegans are maybe
the devolution of man like in 20 years
maybe maybe we're going to turn back
into like the monkeys
[Music]
hi hi nice to meet you hi
[Music]
actually why do you say disagree not
strongly disagree because it depends
what type of meat so what do you mean by
type of me
I personally disagree with eating meat
that has been bought from the
supermarket I don't believe in walking
down a supermarket aisle to these
perfectly wrapped pink pieces of flesh
we've kind of no relationship to whether
from so what type of meat do you
advocate for people to eat
I personally hunt the meat that I eat
myself I don't advocate that everyone
goes out there and hunts because it's
impractical
however I do promote that there is wild
meat available to be purchased online so
I suppose I do advocate to eat meat
that's been responsibly and ethically
sourced over meat that has been produced
in mass factory farmed conditions like
what we both agree on there is that we
want people to be connected to what they
eat and mindlessly shopping in a
supermarket is you know the last thing
we want we want people to be connected
used you use that word ethical earlier
obviously you know that's gonna be where
we have a huge disagreement right when
we kill an animal we don't show respect
them and we take their life from them
completely unnecessarily and it has no
purpose in either of our lives we don't
have to serve either Foley can't be
ethical to take life needlessly could I
ask what do you believe makes your diet
more ethical than mine every time every
single plant crop that you eat well
there will have been animals that died
I'm glad that you use the word more
ethical I I'm happy to admit that in a
vegan diet it's not perfect but what it
is is it's a significant step in the
right direction
[Music]
I'll be strong about that one this is
how I feel about the natural thing is I
can't say that I strongly disagree or
agree I kind of feel that should maybe
be a little bit more in than just
straight banging neutral in the middle
because well I mean because I think at
the end of the day it cannot be denied
that we've eaten meat for thousands of
years Rome and it also can't be denied
that eating meat was a cornerstone in
our survival
you know development in many ways and it
helped us progress to the species that
can't be denied but I think that what is
natural it's kind of a fallacy because
it doesn't translate to how we should
live in today's world you know there's a
lot of things that we don't do that
because it natural so what is natural
doesn't kind of take what is moral or
immoral so I think that it's irrelevant
wherever I'm not eating meat would be
considered something that we have
naturally done for our history because
we've changed so much as a species I
think it's a shame that we've changed
though I think we need to keep that
connection to nature and I really I mean
what you say the science is there you
know we do have the canines we do have
the incisors for ripping and tearing
there's some really interesting
information and studies that people have
found out there about our our early
ancestors and how eating meat and the
specific proteins for me actually made
us human as we are today I do often
wonder if vegans are maybe the
devolution of man like in 20 years maybe
maybe we're going to turn back into like
the monkey song you know because we
stopped eating meat if I had my way in
you know in you have daydreams about you
know we'd all go back to living in caves
or living off the land or living off the
log cabins that's where I find my
enjoyment you'd be dead seriously being
that in that life you'd be dead at first
hey I'd have had a great life you live
day-to-day survival there's no
improvement in their life it's a life of
fear
that's not aspirational life and I think
you can say it's an aspirational life
because you live such a comfortable life
now I think we just live in I I think as
I said if I had it my way it'd be like I
suppose who did the Disney movie in
Bambi they kill the deer and
why everyone's upset because someone
kills the deer and so you say it's like
a Disney movie but you're the bad guy in
the Disney movie but that's the cool
heart now I wouldn't have killed him no
okay but you killed deer that's the
point right so it's because I care about
them that I do shoot them I know that
sounds really weird to you but not
necessarily hear me out so in the UK
deer have no natural predators basically
if I didn't manage the deer in those
woodlands the population would explode
to an extent that that woodlands
basically couldn't support and it would
basically spoil the ecosystem for the
rest of the wildlife I was a vegetarian
when I was a child for the same reasons
that were discussing now I actually got
shingles which was really unusual for
someone of such a young age went to the
doctors
I was really anemic and he said she's
not I mean I'm not saying this is the
case now but back then the diet that I
was having just wasn't meeting my
nutrition or there isn't an inhibitor
anyway but a vegan day is healthier for
you it's not true in its blanket
statement because obviously you could
eat me know Oreos and Doritos all day
and terribly unhealthy but at the same
time if you implement a Whole Foods
plant-based diet you know you're aware
of what your nutrients come from you're
on that then it absolutely can be I'm
staying neutral until there's more
information about vegan diets until
until it's kind of taken its fruition
and you've all turned into monkeys and
then we'll have the conversation well we
may be monkeys but at least we weren't
hopefully not like coronary heart
disease and such
there's a prize surprise surprise so did
you used to eat means absolutely yeah
you meet foot almost 21 years of my life
and did you love animals at the same
time yes I said I did did you you I even
know if you love them why I know I love
like I love my dog I actually tell my
dogs I'm like I love you before I leave
the house so I don't wanna dear no you
don't have to live animals to be vegan
right it's not about oh and I think all
animals are amazing we can cuddle them
all time you can dislike you know snakes
right and not want to kill them I think
it's just about autonomy respect and
understanding that all life all animals
deserve to live without human influence
if you lived in Australia you would not
feel the same about killing snakes trust
me
well maybe this maybe this is a great
reality TV series we'll put loads of
vegans and loads of snakes on a plane
remember the film and we could put lots
of hunters in an area where they don't
have guns and crossbows and they have to
kill the animals themselves trust me
that would probably appeal to a lot of
hunters ghosts I miss my daddy I'm sure
would look very graceful
[Music]
if I open up a for Soros I find the word
humane what other words do I find there
and I find compassion benevolence you
know kindness because you know if you're
a human person you're inherently
benevolent right so for me then I have
to apply those words and say is
slaughter benevolent its lot of
compassionate to me they can't be that
that's not see [ __ ] right because you
can't compassionately take the life of
someone who doesn't have to die so
therefore in the absence of compassion
of benevolence been used humane can't be
used even so I strongly just strongly
agree that it doesn't exist because it
must be an oxymoron find that line of
thinking the problem is that you are
taking life and I'll go back again to
the point I made vegans take millions of
life so why are we why are we different
I'll be perfectly just what's the
alternative okay so I can't be perfect
so you know what let's kill everyone and
do everything because death is
inevitable everyone's gonna die so that
makes the animals that you kill
different to the animals that I kill to
eat it's a reduction in what suffering
and let me make a point as well isn't
there why is it a reduction in suffering
because less animals have been killed
over all oh my god they are not they
start so you will make that point this
is so interesting this is slightly
complicated isn't it because we have
like scales I would say that the life of
a cow is worth more than the life of say
an aphid right like that would make that
thing vibrate about that statement and
so for me like yes if you kill a fish
during crop production it's not ideal
but it's still a more beneficial option
than slaughtering other animals and we
can never eliminate suffering can we we
can make steps to reduce as much as we
can
[Music]
I have to be right down you have to be
down the middle because some do but some
some down and it depends what meats and
depends what because it's what you're
comparing like don't get me wrong right
some vegan cheese is horrific
like the first time I had four you can
cheese I took a bite over and I was like
this is gonna be hard right so I get it
like not all be a component to taste
good some vegan products taste rubbish
some vegan products taste good you know
like some meat products taste good when
I used to eat them and so many products
I didn't like so I can't make a decision
because yeah as you know do you think
it's hypocritical though to be buying
meat substitute products from companies
as you say who have practices that you
don't agree with because she's still
putting money in their pocket and still
supporting the company I feel like if
vegans don't buy these products and
these companies will not make them right
and then if they don't make them then we
can't make vegan food more accessible
it's just in vegan only you know
supermarkets and vegan restaurants and
so no I think we should support them
[Music]
ya know I would I would I think we can
learn from from each other I think
there's room for all of us I think we
definitely need to assess our food
production systems though either way
there's so much we can talk about right
I feel like we agree on a lot it's just
we have this huge moment where we split
that huge moment there is something that
requires a lot of conversation cheers
Cheers
and so what we're gonna have a three
hour long football game because we're
gonna check every decision Plowman
there's no one suggesting that other
you're suggesting that we need to get
every decision right no I'm not
suggesting that how many things are we
gonna get right the important things the
mixing it's a fine important like you
know red cards penalties things like
that